you have a choice i didn't
rosaly hale is one of twilight's most
compelling characters
but you wouldn't know it from just the
movies or even the books
behind her radiant beauty and grace
hides a complex
dark past that's not widely explored we
think rosalie's backstory deserved more
screen time
and here's why hey come over here
we've been waiting for you
based on what we know from the original
four books and what stephanie meyer has
shared
rosalie lillian hale was born in
rochester new york in 1915.
her mother was a housewife and her
father worked at the bank
she also had two younger brothers her
father's job was able to keep them well
off during the great depression
so she lived a pretty privileged life at
that time rosalie has always been
beautiful
even since birth and that became her
defining quality while human
which she liked because of this she
envied how beautiful the mysterious
cullen family was
but since she rarely saw them she didn't
let it consume her
rosalie eventually caught the eye of the
bank owner's son
royce king ii and the two began dating
the relationship was solely based on
physical attraction though
as the two rarely spent time together
rosalie realized this while visiting her
friend
vera and noticing the love between the
couple that her and royce lacked
later that evening rosalie found her
fiance under the influence
while he bragged to his friends about
how beautiful she was
this eventually led to the group of men
brutally attacking rosalie and leaving
her to suffer in the street
she was soon found by carlisle who could
smell her blood
and he decided to turn her into a
vampire to be a potential mate for
edward
during the turning process rosalie's
pain greatly increased
and she eventually woke up to the
cullens arguing about why
carlisle turned rosalie edward openly
rejected rosalie as a romantic partner
which hurt her feelings even though she
wasn't interested in him either
once rosalie felt up to power she went
back and eliminated all of royce's
friends
one at a time she saved royce for last
and made sure it was a drawn out ending
even wearing a wedding dress for a
dramatic flair
it seems that through this rosalie was
able to get closure with her past life
as a human
the blonde girl that's rosalie
while rosalie's ego and vanity were
still dealing with edward's rejection
she was able to start assimilating into
the cullen family
accepting that edward only saw her as a
sister it was all for the best though
because two years into her
transformation
she witnessed someone fighting with a
bear outside gatlinburg tennessee
that young man ended up being emmett
mccarty she resisted the urge to drink
his blood
and instead carried him over 100 miles
so that carlisle could turn him
at her request she chose to save him
because he reminded her of her friend
vera's baby son
henry that seems to give her a tether to
her old life and what she dreamt of
having
which was a loving relationship and a
family once emmett was fully turned
he and rosalie fell madly in love and
her sibling bond with edward was
solidified
rosalie and emmett were never apart from
each other and would sometimes break off
from the main group to spend alone time
together
in midnight's sun edward and rosalie's
strained relationship gets a closer
examination
rosalie strongly disapproves of edward's
love for bella
mainly out of jealousy but it's more
complicated
one might think that the jealousy stems
from edward's rejection of rosalie and
it does a little but rosalie would give
anything to be a human again
and finds bella's desires to become a
vampire to be painful and
a waste in midnight sun rosalie's
frustration with bella is highlighted
again during the infamous
accident scene in twilight it's revealed
that edward knew that both her and
jasper were worried that bella would
realize something's off about the
cullens and blow their cover
rosalie went as far as volunteering to
end bella to protect the family
this all sounds pretty harsh but given
that midnight sun is from edward's
perspective
we are able to get a better and more
sympathetic understanding of rosalie's
position
more so than we did in twilight that's
what i miss the most
possibilities
in the movies we only get to see her
from bella's perspective
which isn't really fair to rosalie's
character she went through a lot before
getting turned which influenced her
demeanor
she comes off as cold and unwelcoming to
bella in twilight
but without knowing her history it seems
like she's just an unkind character
which is not the case given what we know
now there's so much that the movies
could have included about rosalie's
backstory but the question is
why was her backstory altered and pretty
much left out
on one hand time constraints for the
movies was a part of it
but given the incredibly dark nature of
her history
it would have been difficult for the
producers to keep the movie as kid and
teen friendly as they wanted in an
interview with mtv
actress nikki reed who played rosalie in
the movies
shared that she was intimidated by
rosalie's backstory
i think it's a very dark and dramatic
backstory that rosalie has
and stephanie certainly gave me plenty
to work with even rosalie's motivation
to dislike bella wasn't fully explored
in eclipse we only get to see rosalie's
disdain for bella because she thinks
she's wasting her human life by wanting
to be a vampire
that is true but it would have been
great to see a flashback of edward and
rosalie when she was first turned
and why she was jealous of edward's
attraction to bella
i think these alterations to the movie
rosalie made the audience less
sympathetic to her
and also left her as an incredibly
watered down side character
when she actually has a rich enough
history to have her own movie or book
series
did any of these facts about rosalie
surprise you is there anything from here
that you wish the movies would have
included
or are you happy with the final results